Welcome to FOSSDA, the Free and Open
Source Stories Digital Archive Foundation.
It's the 25th of July, 2023, and
I am Elisabetta Mori, an historian of
Computing currently based in Italy, and an
oral history interview with FOSSDA.
Today I'll be talking to Cat Allman.
Cat has been involved in open source
software since the 1980s and worked with
the global free and open source software
community at Google.
We are recording on theirstory.io and I
am in Rio, Elba Island, Italy, and
Cat is in San Francisco, US.
Welcome, Cat.
Thank you for being here today.
Can you talk about your childhood?
Sure.
I was born in Oakland, in Oakland,
California, in 1958, and raised in the
East Bay Hills, looking out across San
Francisco Bay to the Golden Gate Bridge
in San Francisco with my older brother
Eric Allman, creator, original creator of Send
Mail, the mail transfer agent.
Went to public schools, ending up at
University of California, Santa Cruz, where I
studied American Studies, so not engineering, not
computer science.
Growing up with an older brother who
was a science child prodigy put me
on another path for a while, though
because of his interests we grew up
with like boxes of punch cards, which
it turns out if you make a
cone out of them and staple them
and spray paint them gold, you can
make a Christmas wreath out of them,
which we did do because super nerdy,
what can I say?
Fast forward to out of school looking
for a job and that was the
early 1980s and computers were just coming
online as business tools.
It was right before personal computers, so
many computers were the rage and I
was working for a advertising media planning
firm that not only specialized in technology
clients, but was one of the first
to have a computerized, essentially, work tracking
system.
So whether I wanted to or not,
there I was working with computers.
In the meantime, I was close as
I always have been with my brother
and his group of friends.
Fast forward a little bit and my
first job with free and open source
software was at Mount Zainu.
Mount Zainu is Unix trademark backwards.
Our logo was a little mountain range.
I was a contractor, not an employee,
but so I was working on coordinating
the company's involvement with DECUS, which was
the DEC User Group Conference.
And found myself really kind of engaged
with the political idea of software that
had been created at a publicly funded
institution as being free and available to
the rest of us to use.
Really the academic method of, you know,
you come up with an idea and
other people build on it and civilization
rolls along.
There's a lot more history behind that,
including a protracted intellectual property lawsuit between
AT&T and the University of California, because
Mount Zainu was selling the first commercially
supported release of what is now known
as Berkeley Unix.
But the other thing that happened, that
was a collective.
So every Wednesday, we gathered in the
conference room and argued every decision to
a halt.
And there was the one guy who
gave up last, so he usually got
his way.
And then we had burritos, because it
was California.
But I was a contractor, so then
I was out of work again and
ended up working at Axion Design.
At the time it was called DeVito
and Associates and it was one of
the most prominent package design and branding
firms in the United States.
And it was all done on paper.
I was running a darkroom and literally
mixing bottles of ink to make custom
materials for the artists to make mock-ups
of package designs.
But right about that time, computers started
coming along in the design industry.
And I already had experience using a
computer which no one except the COO
had and so we started expanding the
offerings, the internal offerings to include computers
not free and open source software but
software.
That rolled along, ended up being an
IT manager back in the days when
you could actually make a profit by
selling computer services.
Now it would be like having pay
toilets, but at the time you could
charge by, I think we charged on
five minute increments for the designers using
the computers that I bought and managed
to do graphic design work.
Do you remember computers were at the
time?
Originally we just had one Microsoft AT,
PC AT.
It was actually pre-Windows, So it was
command line, but just barely.
And then the Macintosh came along and
we started right about the time you
started having color available on the Macintosh.
A friend had lent me the original
Macintosh.
So early on, I was able to
connect to a deck of backs at
the University of California to send email
back and forth with my friends.
Kind of open source.
I should mention all this predates the
development of the term free software as
popularized by Richard Stallman, or open source.
The term open source came later in
the late 1990s.
So, looping that all together, how did
I get started actually in free and
open source software?
I was sick of my job, but
I liked engineers.
I really admired not just the way
my brother and his friends organized the
world, but the people I met through
the software industry in the graphic design
field actually tried to put together a
community in the San Francisco Bay Area
for people doing IT management for advertising
and graphic design.
It didn't really go anywhere but it
was interesting to try.
So about this time the idea of
businesses based on free and open source
software started percolating around.
I mean, there'd been, what were they
called?
There had been an earlier company doing
BSD, CD ROMs, etc.
I'm embarrassed I can't remember their name,
but anyway, they were there.
So my brother around that time, that
would be 1997, had a former colleague
who they were talking together about doing
something with Sendmail in terms of starting
a business around it.
My brother wouldn't hire me because nepotism,
he's a very principled guy, so I
started harassing his business partner to give
me a job as they were putting
this idea of a company together.
And he finally gave up and hired
me.
So I was employee number five at
Sendmail Inc.
And was there when we launched the
company, which I look back on it,
and it was kind of embarrassing, some
of the choices I had made, but
it was a really heady time.
At that point, we were going to
ISP-focused conferences, as that was really a
stronghold for the use of free and
open source software, was the ISP business,
back when people could start a local
ISP and actually end up making money.
It didn't last long, but it was
kind of glorious while it lasted.
And then about that same time, 1998,
I think, yes, I have the t-shirt.
O'Reilly and Company, the media people, the
animal books, did a, as I recall
it, it was an evening event at
a conference room at Stanford University about
free and open source software.
I should have brought the t-shirt to
the interview.
And we were there for that.
And suddenly the world was in a
dot-com bubble, and not just a dot-com
bubble, but a hybrid business model, open
source software bubble.
We actually got landed on the front
page of the New York Times when
we launched the company, which was pretty
heady for the five of us, but
the technology reporter at the time understood
the importance of what Sendmail has done
to actually create the Internet.
And also by that time, Tim Berners-Lee
had invented the World Wide Web.
It's funny looking back on, I remember
bringing my original Macintosh to my office
and showing my boss email and he
was like, why would anybody want to
use this?
And then some years later we brought
a color Macintosh in and showed him
the World Wide Web and he was
like, why would anyone care?
Well, needless to say, 30, 40 years,
things are a little different.
And I think, you know, for the
regular user, they don't necessarily understand or
need to understand how important floss has
been to the development of the Internet
and the World Wide Web.
But as I said to a fellow
panelist actually at Maker Faire Rome, a
banking guy who was saying, "oh, we
don't use any open source software in
my Italian bank." And I'm like, "do
you send email to clients bank online?"
He's like, "well, yeah." I'm like, "you
look, you're using free and open source
software." And the look of horror on
the poor man's face was really fun.
But anyway, so that was interesting being
in the dot-com bubble.
Heady times, stupid parties.
But what was really important for the
development of my engagement was, I mean,
I started out as the marketing manager,
but as we grew, I did not
maintain that title, but I was the
one that got all the email coming
into info at and sorted it out
and answered a lot of questions and
redirected people where they needed to go.
Now that was mail coming into the
company as a hybrid business model, we
had Sendmail the projects and mail.org and
Sendmail.com the company.
So I was dealing with the company
email and it was it was interesting
times.
People are very passionate about software that
they work on.
And Frankly, that passion is a big
part of why I've stayed involved with
free and open source software over the
decades.
I never want to be in one
of those jobs where people don't care.
And so far, at least, people involved
with free and open source really care.
And that means, I mean, life is
short and you don't have time at
work.
So you might as well spend it
with people.
Even if you don't always agree with
them, you respect their commitment to their
ideas.
So here I am.
Plus, I like solving problems and free
software, open source software, it's all about
solving problems and working collectively to make
things better for all of us.
Sometimes not so much together.
There's the XKCD comic of the enormous
infrastructure that holds up the world and
there's one little block at the bottom
maintained by one guy.
But that's another interesting thing is the
sustainability of free and open source software
as it is increasingly relied upon by
the world, really the global infrastructure of
information.
So fast forward, I worked at Send
Mail for about four years and I
took some time off and the USENIX
Association is something that I had known
for a long time.
When I was an IT manager I
went to their conferences focused on IT
services and I knew the executive director
and people involved.
My brother and my brother-in-law had been
involved.
So when the executive director called me
and asked me to come in and
do what amounted to fundraising, marketing and
fundraising for them, I was ready for
another job.
So I worked there for years.
But one of our sponsors, I was
about to call them a client because
they were kind of a client, was
Google, early Google.
And my brother had told me about
this cool new search engine in 1999
I think and then I remember really
wanting a Gmail email address even though
a friend was running my own domain
for me.
So Google recruiting had booths and advertisements
on the Unix platform, Usenix platform.
I'll be careful to pronounce that right.
So I knew some people there.
And then someone I knew from the
dot com bubble when he was at
VA Linux was now the head of
Google's OSPO.
People argue whether Google had the first
OSPO or whether Sun Microsystems did.
I don't know that it really matters,
but if you want to have a
heated conversation in a bar late at
night, at certain circumstances, you can bring
that up.
So, actually the first job I applied
to at Google they wouldn't even talk
to me which was disappointing, but c'est
la vie.
But then I saw Chris DeBona at
an open source conference and one of
the people working at Google had made
a unfortunate error in something they were
doing and I had been able to
correct it for them before it got
bad.
So I was aware that there might
be a need there for help with
working with the free and open source
software community.
So I saw Chris and I'm like,
"hey, Chris, need any help?" And he
said, "Yeah, why don't you apply?" So
you asked me about interviews, it took
four months.
And three rounds of interviews, I think
I interviewed with eight people.
And my recruiter was funny after I
was hired.
She said, "you know, Google staffing didn't
even want to give you a phone
screen." I'm like, okay.
But the free and open source software
community takes care of its own, if
you will.
Not only Chris went and said, "no,
really, you have to hire her", but
a gentleman named Rob Pike, who had
been involved with the Unix operating system
since the 1980s, and more recently was
the original creator of the Go system.
When you apply to Google, at least
it used to be, they would send
an email around internally saying, do you
know this person?
Because you have to put a list
of people you know working at Google
on your application.
So Rob said something really nice for
me.
And since Rob had been at Bell
Labs and was generally very well respected,
I told him I'd make him some
brownies and he's like, no, it's my
job.
Rob's kind of like that.
So they eventually broke down and hired
me.
And yeah, it was very exciting to
try working at a big company.
I have to say my first day
was spent in a windowless room in
a group for an orientation with all
these extraordinarily perky videos.
And I went home in tears because
I thought oh my god I've made
a terrible mistake.
But unlike most people at least at
the time who applied to Google I
went into it knowing who I was
going to work for and what I
was going to work on.
I didn't go to work at Google,
I went to work on free and
open source software at Google.
So that's what I did.
It's part of the outreach team.
So we did things like, Google Summer
of Code came from there, as well
as Google Code-In, which was a program
like Google Summer of Code, but for
teenagers, which was actually even more inspiring,
I think, than Google Summer of Code.
I should mention in case it's not
clear, Google Summer of Code is a
program that Google has been running since
2005, where they work, open source projects
can apply to be mentoring organizations for
a period of months, where they will
accept, used to be students, now it
can be anybody, to work on their
projects, Google supplies a stipend for the
contributor, they're called now, they used to
be called students, now they're called contributors,
to work with that project directly on
pre-agreed upon projects to benefit that project.
Ultimately, as I know the origin story,
Google Summer of Code came about because
Larry Page came up behind Chris DeBona,
Larry Page being one of Google's founders,
came up behind Chris DeBona, the head
of the open source programs office, and
said, it seems like people, students are
losing their skills over the summer working
non-computer related jobs fixed that.
And Chris being Chris saw it as
an opportunity to get more people contributing
to free and open source software.
So that's what he did.
He designed a program that addressed Larry's
concerns while pulling more people into the
free and open source software movement and
getting projects that were interested in mentoring
new contributors some help getting those people
engaged.
It's still going on.
I'm trying to think.
Last time I ran the numbers, which
was a few years ago, we had
worked with over 650 projects from around
the world and many thousands not only
of students but mentors.
I have to say it's one of
the things I'm really proud of having
been able to support in any way.
It's, you meet all kinds of people
working in our funny little ecosystem and
working on GSoC gave me the opportunity
to meet a heck of a lot
of them, which I really cherish that.
I was always kind of envious that
my brother and his friends working in
computer science got to travel and knew
people all over the world and had
this pretty vast network of friends and
colleagues.
And by working on Summer of Code
in particular, I got to have that
too.
And I got to travel, woo, which
I really wanted to do.
We did a certain amount of outreach
to encourage more participation, particularly in underrepresented
areas, so I've had the opportunity to
speak at engineering schools in Singapore and
Cambodia, Vietnam, Germany, India, let's see, Taiwan,
a bunch of places.
It's still haven't gotten to South America,
that's very disappointing.
But I did get to Australia and
New Zealand quite a bit, which was
wonderful.
That I mean, aside from the fact
that open source drives the global economy
by providing the underlying infrastructure for computer
services.
The global network of people engaged in
this is incredibly important to me, and
not just because I'm talking to somebody
who's in Italy right now, but there's
a lot of divisiveness in the world
right now.
And I'm not saying everything in free
and open source software is all kittens
and rainbows because there are some fairly
extreme personalities involved.
But overall, what I hear from people,
past participants in GSoC, is that participating
in open source has expanded their knowledge
of the world, be it coming from
a secondary engineering school in Sri Lanka
and ending up in a PhD program
in the United States or simply having
the opportunity to work with people who
are clear around the world from them.
And it can't be discounted that as
the awareness for free and open source
software in industry has grown, it is
participating in floss is increasingly a requirement
to get a job.
So there's the economic opportunity, which is
something I used to talk about at
engineering schools in places like Phnom Penh.
The engineering school I spoke at there
didn't have glass in the windows, but
they did have computers and wonderfully optimistic
and hungry population of students who wanted
to make their lives better and the
lives of their families better and open
source gave them a way to do
that.
So I feel very privileged to have
been a part of it in any
way.
And since I mentioned any way, I
should bring up alternative forms of contribution.
I was reluctant to do this interview
because in a lot of ways I
still feel like I'm not a real
floss contributor because I don't code.
I mean, I noodled around with PostScript
back in the day, but I'm not
a coder, nor do I have formal
engineering training.
So I've always felt like an imposter.
At the same time, something that has
been wonderful to see over the last
30-ish years is, 30, 25, 25 years,
is the growing appreciation for non-code contributions.
People coming to appreciate that they're not
just nice to have, like, oh, somebody
got us coffee, but critical to have,
be it raising money so that people
have the equipment and bandwidth they need.
Thank God people are figuring out documentation.
But also the community building, which is
really where I find myself really focused.
The past several years I've been focused
on a conference that I'm deeply proud
to be a contributor to as a
co-organizer called Science Foo Camp with O'Reilly
Media.
The Foo stands for Friends of O'Reilly.
Nature, the scientific publishing company, and Digital
Science, which is a company in the
same media group as Nature that builds
digital tools to aid scientific research.
It's an interdisciplinary conference where we invite
people from up and down the career
stack and all across the spectrum of
the sciences to come together for an
unconference.
An unconference being essentially the hallway track,
all those fascinating, weird conversations you have
in the hallways and over meals at
conferences.
An unconference gives you the opportunity to
focus the entire event on those kinds
of conversations, what people are thinking about
now, what they're maybe planning to do
and want feedback on.
So I've been working on this conference,
SciFu as we call it, since 2007
when I started at Google.
Because back then my manager at the
time, not Chris, didn't, she wanted to
focus more specifically on software.
And the concept of open science, open
data, open hardware to a lesser extent
was really new.
And so I stepped in to get
to be Google's lead on it, which
I really enjoy, and I am continuing
to do that to this day, including
creating an alumni community for past participants
in the conference.
So it ranges far afield from strictly
open source, open science, etc.
But increasingly, you can't do science without
computers.
I mean, you still, there's the natural
world and reagents and lab equipment, et
cetera, and computers are ubiquitous.
And increasingly people are appreciating, especially in
the US, as budgets for academic research
are increasingly not keeping pace with inflation.
The opportunity to use free and open
source software in place of commercial programs
is increasingly important.
And, for example, the Carpentries, which you
may have heard of, was a participant
in the ESOC a number of times.
One of my favorite projects because it
is a program that pulls together volunteer-driven
workshops at universities and research institutions, not
just in the US but around the
world, to teach researchers the basics of
using free and open source software to
accomplish their research.
So it's kind of a, I don't
want to call it a gateway drug
because that sounds nefarious, but It does,
again, pull more people into the ecosystem
and benefits science, which I think benefits
us all.
And I've been talking nonstop and not
giving you a chance to ask any
questions.
So hit me.
That's fine.
So what do you think are the
challenges and opportunities that you built, the
impact you had on building these communities?
Ah, well, while I was helping with-
speaking about Google, I actually had a
job job in addition to managing the
team at one point, teams at the
same time.
But anyway, my job "job" was choosing
projects to provide sponsorship money to and
getting that money out to them, largely
for events, but also direct sponsorships of
open source projects and organizations.
Which I gotta say, as jobs go,
having been on the other side of
the desk, asking for money for a
nonprofit, getting to give money to nonprofits
is rather enjoyable, especially by comparison.
It's really satisfying to know that you
can, I shouldn't say this, but I'm
going to use Google's money to support
something I believe in?
Also, because a lot of sponsorships coming
from commercial organizations to FLOSS projects are
earmarked specifically there to sponsor conferences where
people get marketing exposure, or if it's
not event-related or program-related, it tends to
be tied to a specific development effort.
When I was doing it, I always
tried as much as possible to make
it an unsecured sponsorship, so that the
projects could use it for unglamorous things
like bandwidths and paying people to do
the kind of work that companies don't
want to pay for and that volunteers
aren't interested in doing, doing the grunge
work.
All the overhead stuff that people don't
realize exists because, hey, it's free software,
it's all free, right?
Not so much really.
Back in the day, you had to
pay your ISP bill.
Now, you may have cloud services bills,
you may need new hardware, you may
want to bring your developers together from
time to time physically to brainstorm your
roadmap for the next year.
So lots of things to think about,
actually.
Challenges going forward to the FLOSS ecosystem.
Something that I'm really concerned about, And
I'm conflicted about it is, FLOSS is
one of those 20 plus year overnight
successes.
It's been around a long time, but
it's only now that people, businesses are
appreciating how essential it is.
At the same time, they still want
the code for free.
I mean, lots of businesses like Google
are understanding the importance of working with
projects so that they are sustainable, they
have the economic and other resources that
they need to continue.
But what I worry about is the
psychological aspects.
Back when free and open source software
was done by people who cared passionately
about it.
I mean, back in the day, people
didn't go into computer science because, oh,
I'm going to get rich.
They would go to law school or
something like that.
They would get a business degree.
But now, computer science is seen as
a safe way to make a good
living.
Nothing wrong with that, but FLOSS has
been a volunteer ecosystem, and when you
make it a requirement to get a
job, then it becomes a transactional ecosystem
in a way that it wasn't before.
And what I'm hearing from younger students
in particular, and some older ones too,
is that they want to get paid.
Yes, it's free software, but they don't
want to do the development work unless
they are getting paid.
Corporations are making large sums of money
on the backs of people who have
done it for love.
And at this point, they want to
get paid.
And who can blame them?
It's almost like free and open source
software development is that extra job that
theoretically women have.
You know they work all day and
then they come home and they've got
their second job in the home.
Well, now people have their day job
and then they come home and they
code at night.
And I really see that volunteer flywheel
breaking down, so much so that I'm
really worried about it, actually, that if
people stop volunteering, that the licensing structure
won't hold.
Also as you have companies who start
out as free and open source software
hybrid businesses relicensing their software in such
a way that it is no longer
compliant with the Open Source Initiative definitions
of the various licenses.
And I mean, I don't know how
to do that.
Goodwill is not an engine.
If you have to apply heat in
the form of money, I don't know.
I don't know that the center is
going to hold and that the system
is going to hold up.
I worry that in about five years
it's all going to have broken down,
which would be a shame.
I mean, on the one hand, everything
has a life cycle and the wheel
turns and that's just what happens, but
I would really hate to see the
force of innovation in community that FLOSS
has been for me and my network
of friends die.
I don't know how we fix this.
I don't know how we, what I
don't want to have happen is that
people in under-resourced countries continue to participate
in free and open source software as
a way to make some money and
potentially move to a higher resourced area,
but that becomes a kind of digital
serfdom, and I really don't want to
see that happen.
More than it already is with data
sets for large learning models, but that's
another thing.
So that's my concern and I don't
know what's going to happen.
It's been interesting to watch.
It seems increasingly like there is a
movement in the United States to discontinue
open source programs offices and take the
compliance, license compliance and other aspects that
are generally managed by OSPOs and spread
them out so that the compliance goes
to legal and the sponsorship for sustainability
goes to marketing and again I would
hate to see that happen because having,
we'll say, pushed back against various marketing
teams over several decades, I think that
has the potential to exacerbate the shift
from volunteerism and really altruism and in,
well, I'll call it altruism, call it
enlightened self-interest of participating in free and
open source to a strictly commercial relationship.
But I hope I'm just being pessimistic.
We'll see.
Oh, dear.
I hope we're not frozen.
Okay, sorry, I'm going to rephrase.
So, what activities have you pursued since
you left Google?
Ah, well, I honestly thought when I
got laid off from Google that the
boards I was on would ask me
to step down so they could get
another Google person.
But I'm happy to say that in
both cases, they were like, actually all
three cases, they were like, "no, no,
we want you, not the company." So
that's good.
In fact, the IEEE one wanted me
to be vice chair.
So I'm doing that.
Can you name these boards?
Sure.
Committee for the, God it's so long,
the digital testbed out of universities in
Oregon and British Columbia.
And apologies to John Fink, who's rolling
his eyes at me right now, one
moment.
Okay, Digital Testbed Center Advisory Board.
Let me get this important, and maybe
you can edit it for me.
I lost you.
Portland State University Digital Cities Test FreeBSD
Foundation Board and the committee for IEEE
Standards Association Open Source Committee, OSCON, are
the official boards I'm on.
I'm also, my main thing I've been
working on is, I've been contracting with
digital science out of the UK to
help land that while working closely not
only with O'Reilly and nature but also
Google because when they laid me off
they didn't cancel the program, they just
laid off the only person working on
it.
And I knew the person that they
drafted to pick up my work, and
I wasn't just going to leave her
twisting in the wind.
An event came down the weekend before
last, mid-July, excuse me.
And we are already deep in conversation
about 2024.
People have given me grief for when
I'm not getting paid, at least not
as much as I was.
But the truth is, I really love
what I do.
And I'm not going to stop.
The great thing is it's not a
Google program so Google legal can't make
me stop.
Plus it looks like I'm going to
be working for digital science as an
employee to continue not only the conference
itself, looks like we're gonna be doing
it at Cambridge University next summer, which
I'm super excited about.
I mean, Cambridge, but also the alumni
community.
It's not large, but with a thousand
opinionated people, it's sometimes a handful.
But obviously during COVID, we talked about
COVID and vaccine science.
Right now we're talking about AI because
the world is talking about AI, but
lots of other things going on.
And it's pretty heady when somebody talks
about public health to have someone like
Larry Brilliant, who was on the team
that ended smallpox, chime in.
Or Vint Cerf, arguably the father of
the internet, will pop in and always
ask, I love, his messages are always
very brief.
There's that old saying, it's, I would
have written a short, I didn't have
time to write a short message, so
I wrote a long one.
Vint writes short messages because he's just
that smart, which is really fun to
watch.
So yeah, that's what I'm doing.
FreeBSD project, we're working with Core.
The project is run, there's the foundation,
the nonprofit that provides essentially support services,
etc.
For the project, which is managed by
kind of an elected group of people
called core, and they're the technical people
that are doing the technical work.
And collectively, we're trying to work more
closely together so that we can coordinate
our efforts to make everything better.
Not that things are bad, but just
making it better.
So if you look at your career,
is there anything you would do differently
if you had your time again?
And why?
If I could start over in junior
high school now, I would have been
less of a visible nerd, more of
a stealth nerd, and probably gone into
the biological sciences in some respects.
But the truth is, I don't want
to do over because I love my
life.
People are wonderful.
I mean, not everybody.
I mean, I live in America.
People suck sometimes, but the community that
I have found in free and open
source software, it's a wonderful thing with
a really interesting group of people.
And I can be as nerdy as
I want to be, which makes me
very happy.
And I can feel like in whatever
small way I'm contributing to making the
world better, which matters to me.
I hope it matters to a lot
of people.
I think it matters to more than
the average percent of people in the
FLOSS world, which once again, here I
am.
So.
So is there a project you're particularly
proud of or what is your proudest
achievement?
At the risk of sounding hopelessly vain,
it's hard to pick because there are
several.
Being involved with Google Summer of Code
was such a blessing.
I wasn't as involved with Google Code
in the high school program, but it
was really inspiring and reassuring to meet
kids, I can call them kids because
they're under 18, from all over the
world that were just that smart and
that passionate about what they were doing.
In terms of funding, at one point
we had spun up a team inside
Google called Making in Science, specifically addressing
DOI, Making in Science, or more specifically
STEM education.
At one point I had money left
over in a budget there, so there's
the WikiEDU project, which is a spin-out
of the Wikimedia Foundation, where they have
a program working with professors to have
students learn how to, to Wikipedia, improving
their science skills and also so that
writing term papers that end up in
their parents' basement, they write Wikipedia articles
increasing the amount of knowledge available to
us all.
In one month, they did a year
of science with a specific focus on
increasing content in Wikipedia about women in
science, in one month alone, that content
increased by, I forget if it was
7 or 14%.
And when you think about the impact
of just that much more knowledge about
the importance of women in science, I
am really proud about having been able
to provide financial support for that effort.
So talking about diversity in the computer
science industry, what are your thoughts for
the future?
Well, Back in the 80s when I
got involved with this, yes, there were
still more men than women, but there
were a lot of women in the
academic setting.
I knew a number of female professors
and contributors.
So I didn't really see it as
an issue, but then as computer science
became more business focused and more people
studied for the career opportunities rather than
passion, that number decreased.
And it took me a while to
notice, really, because I would go to
conferences in the 90s, and people would
say, "oh, women are in open source.
I'm like, what are you talking about?
This person and that person.
Then I realized those ladies are retiring
and they're not necessarily being replaced by
female professors.
So there was an issue and yes,
at one point I was at a
conference about C++.
And I looked around the room and
I realized out of 50 people, I
was the only woman.
And then a guy said something about
making him a sandwich.
I was like, "oh, okay, that's what
they were talking about.
Got it." And I tell friends of
mine in other industries, some of the
stories of what it was like in
the 80s and what it was like.
Because there was definitely a boys club
and not just a lack of respect,
but disrespect towards people in non-coding world.
And the assumption that if you were
female, you were not able to code
and therefore not good at coding.
And I hadn't realized how much I
had internalized that, but yeah.
I'm delighted to say it isn't applied
equally globally.
For example, I went to give a
talk about Summer of Code at a
university in Oman in the Middle East.
Before I agreed to go, I looked
and the enrollment in the computer science
department at that university skewed female.
There were more women in the computer
science department than there were men.
So even though I went to this
university where the women were all fully
covered up except for their hands and
their faces, not only were the majority
of the students female, but the students
who were most engaged and passionate about
free and open source software specifically were
all women.
And my understanding is that that is,
it's in places where, well I'm not
going to say that, but long story
short, sorry for rambling.
I think the potential is there for
it to be better.
I think as with American politics, we
are seeing a backlash as people see
women coming in and not just women
but underrepresented groups coming in see that
as a loss of privilege rather than
as an expansion of opportunity for everyone.
But maybe the increasing ubiquity of FLOSS
will address some of this, because the
upside of market forces is it's harder
to be a jerk if there's money
on the table.
So except if, well, maybe that's true.
Actually, I'm second guessing myself.
I would like that it's going to
get better.
One thing I have noticed in the
past is some of our students, particularly
the high school students, they tell me
about how the educational system in their
country is modeled in such a way
that, what's the word, individual initiative is
discouraged rather than encouraged.
I would argue that one reason why
FLOSS has been as centered as it
has been in the US and Western
Europe is because the education system provides
more opportunity for students to pursue things
they're interested in rather than in following
a strict, largely focused on memorization of
existing content.
That's just my feeling, I have no
facts to back this up, so don't
quote me, but yeah, I don't know
what's going to happen there.
It'll be interesting.
It'll be interesting to see what happens
with China, though the downside of trying
to look to China to see a
rise of open-source software is the difficulties
with licenses and license compliance, but that's
a story for lawyers.
What advice would you give to someone
that might want to pursue your career?
Be brave, be humble, but don't doubt
yourself.
If imposter syndrome were fatal, I would
be dead.
So trust yourself.
Trust yourself and enjoy yourself and pick
your battles.
If you get angry about every little
thing, you're gonna be angry a lot
and that's a waste of time and
energy.
On the other hand, don't let people...
regulate accounts.
Yeah, I have to say the world
has gotten better.
And it's hard to recognize that when
it's happening to you.
But I like to tell people, some
of my colleagues, that for example, when
I started working out of college, help
wanted ads were segregated by gender.
You couldn't even apply to certain jobs
if you were female.
I was in a session at a
conference about diversity and equity and going
around the room and people sharing their
concerns and one person was very upset
about people using the word guys as
an inclusive pronoun.
Hey guys, we're going to go to...
they felt very excluded by this.
And then it was my turn and
I talked about the time I was
in a staff meeting at the design
firm and the senior most designer announced
her pregnancy and the CEO of the
company looked at her and said, "well
you are going to get an abortion
aren't you?" Things are better now.
Things are.
It's hard to see and they're not
necessarily great, but they are better.
And so don't lose hope, even though
there are times when you want to
wring people's necks.
Is there anything you would like to
add that we haven't covered today?
Well I pontificated at length.
So just to follow your passions.
At Maker Faires past, Google had a
booth where we displayed people's personal projects
as well as prototypes for things like
early Google Glass, etc.
And I would bring hyperbolic crochet, which
you might say, what the heck is
hyperbolic crochet?
Well, it is crochet that models fractal
equations in yarn.
It was originally hit upon by a
math professor I think at the University
of Chicago when she realized that her
students couldn't visualize the results of fractal
equations, and that then she figured out
that crochet would be the perfect way
to build physical models of these rates
of growth.
And from this, then two sisters, the
Wertheim Sisters, started the Institute for Figuring,
talking about the intersection between handcrafts and
mathematics.
So it's both a woman's studies project
and a science project and a citizen
science project.
It's all over the world, including the
Smithsonian Museum of Natural History in Washington,
D.C.
There are assembled reefs, because coral reef,
as in the ocean, as well as
various kinds of plants, waterways, much of
life, grow in fractals, these repeating patterns
of growth.
So, I crochet them out of nice
soft squishy yarn and send them in
and they're assembled into these art projects.
The most recent one I believe was
in Hamburg.
Beautiful stuff.
So I bring this up because at
the Maker Faire there's soldering, and there's
robots, and there's stuff that's on fire.
And I had a probably three times
size model of the human cerebellum in
crochet.
So there was this big fuzzy squishy
object and not all women or little
girls but sometimes other people would come
through with their eyes glazed because they
were tired of electronics and they would
see yarn and they would get very
excited.
You could explain how it's like plants
grow, it's the way galaxies grow, you
can make it yourself, it's really easy
and it's really impressive looking and it's
soft and squishy.
So it's not coding.
It's the simplest kind of math, but
it's something that I really enjoy, and
through it I was able to convince
at least a handful of people that
math isn't all scary.
So do what you enjoy because life
is short and you might as well
have fun.
Thank you Cat.
It's been a real pleasure talking to
you today.
Thank you.
I appreciate the opportunity to pontificate.